مساء الخير الولايات المتحده يمكن ان توفر
او تتساهل مع
اختلافات كثيره سواء من خصومها او اعدائها
يمكن مثلا ان هي تتسامح مع دوله حليفه
وترفع شعارات
سياسيه معاديه ليها او حتى اجنده وشعارات
اسلاميه زي ما هو حاله الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان ويمكن اكثر من ذلك ان تتسامح
مع دوله زي باكستان حليفه لها لكنها تدعم
وتمد بالسلاح جماعه طالبان وهي تعبر عن
الولايات المتحده مشتركه في حرب مفتوحه
معها على الساحه الافغانيه ولكن ما لا
يمكن ان تتسامح في امريكا ابدا هو ان ترفع
اي دوله سواء كانت صديقه او عدو اي شعارات
او اي اجندات معاديه الراسماليه هو اقتصاد
السوق السوق يعني كابتال لازم اذا كنتم
يعني تشككون في كلامي انظروا الى الحاله
الفنزويليه اللي اشتعلت ساحتها مؤخرا بشكل
كبير بعدما اعلن رئيس البرلمان التي تسيطر
عليه المعارضه نفسه رئيسا مؤقتا للبلاد
وقدمنا واصبحنا ودام بلد فيها رئيس رئيس
يقول اننا الرئيس المؤقت وتدعم واشنطن
ومجموعه غير قليله من دول الجوار لفنزويلا
في الارجنتين وزير البرازيل ورئيس فعلى
للبلاد اللي هو نيكولاس نكولو نيكولاس
مادورو
الحقيقه لما تيجي تحولت فهم الازمه في
فنزويلا ممكن تلاقي تفاصيل كثيره جدا
اسماء وشخوص خلفيات احداث
لكن كل الاحداث دي المفروض انها
الاسباب الحقيقيه اللي وراء الازمه اللي
مستمره بالها سنين طويله في تقديري
المتواضع سببين السبب ثالث طويله السبب
الاول انه هو ان فينزويلا بلد اقتصاد ريعي
متخلف وتخلي بمعنى بمعنى انه تصدر
تخلف يقوم على سلعه واحده بس وفي حاله
فنزويلا
هو البترول ما قد لا يعلمه البعض ان
فنزويلا الدوله الفقيره اللي عندها شبه
مجاعات هي اكبر بلد في العالم من حيث
الاحتياطات المؤكده من البترول الاحتياطات
المؤكده من البترول مش اللي بت ستخرج
المؤكده الاحتياطات الريف حوالي ستمائه
مليار برميل بطول يعني اكبر من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وعلى مدى سنين طويله جدا بيعيش الاقتصاد
الفنزويلي على ريع هذا البترول بتطلع بطول
وبعدين انت بتسموا على مواطنيها في شكل
دعم الاغذيه والبترول والتعليم والكهرباء
الى اخره تتشابه في كده مع الدول كثيره من
الدول المنتجه للبترول في الجزائر بدينا
زي كل دول الخليج مثلا بردو انت ال
المشكله لما بيكون دوله اقتصاد ريعي
بتعتمد على على البترول اه علشان
اكثر من تسعين في المائه من عوائد الخزانه
العامه بتكون تحت رحمه تقلبات اسعار
البترول وهو دا السبب الرئيس لمشكله اه
فنزويلا زي ما ان والسبب في كثير من مشاكل
دول المنطقه ومنهم بالكثير مش موضوعنا ما
نشوف تاريخ الازمات والاضطرابات في
فنزويلا ت لانه مرتبط تماما بمؤشرات اسعار
النفط اذا كانت المؤشرات او ذكره الاسعار
مرتفعه في استقرار في فنزويلا
واذا انخفضت الاسعار في اضطرابات في
فنزويلا واذا شفنا الاضطرابات اللي موجوده
حاليا هلا انخفاض اسعار البترول سبب رئيسي
فيها واذا شوفنا الازمه من بدايتها خالص
اللائي البترول سبب رئيسي فيها تمام زي
الموقف من الولايات المتحده يقول القصه
باختصار لو حبينا نرجع الازمه الحاليه
لفنزويلا الى طريق حدد ربما يكون منتصف
الثمانينات اقر بحاجه ل تفسير الظاهره
الموجوده دي الوقتي
ايه اللي حصل في منتصف الثمانينيات من
القرن الماضي حصل الازمه في اسعار البترول
انخفاض كبير في اسعار البترول وبالتالي ال
حصلت ازمه اقتصاديه في فنزويلا
العوائد اللي لما العوائد اللي الحكومه
وقتها وجدت نفسها قدام مشكله كبيره انه هي
مش قادره تنفق على برامج الرعايه
الاجتماعيه وعلى الدعم في التعليم والاكل
وخلافه
الحكومه قررت ان تعود الناس من عويد اللي
تقول بانها تستدين ومشهد الامور لكن لما
جاء الرئيس
كارلوس بيريز في سنه
ثمانيه وثمانين بعدما فشلت ثمانيه وثمانين
قرر انه يعمل تغيير كبير في سياسات على
سياسات الحكومات اللي سبقته وقرر يتبنى
معرفتها يعني هو قرار بالبرنامج اصلاح
اقتصادي وقتها
او التحول العظيمه هو ليتحول عظيم لانه
دائما كانت سياسات غير مسبوقه وقتها في
فنزويلا
دوله بتقوم اقتصاد ريعي بيقوم على ان ناخذ
البترول وادب للناس يعني تكلفه معيشه
مقبوله فكانت تحول كبير الامر الثاني انه
كانت تحول اساسا عن برنامج بيريز اللي
تولى السلطه زي ما قلت الحضارات سنه
ثمانيه وثمانين هو نفسه كان ب يرفع شعارات
معاديه
وصندوق النقد الدولي اللي هو تبناها
بالكامل سنه تسعه وثمانين لما تبني
البرنامج العنيفه اللي بيقوم على تقليص
الدعم ال اكبر قدر ممكن واه تحرير اسعار
كثير من السلع الاساسيه كانت النتيجه
وطبعا خفض الرواتب وتقليص العماله في
الحكومه الى اخره كانت النتيجه انه حصل
عليه لان كان النتيجه المباشره ارتفاع
اسعار البترول وبالتالي
وارتفاع اسعار كثير من السلع الحيويه
للناس التي حصلت موجه عنيفه جدا من
الاحتكاكات اظن في فبراير سنه تسعه
وثمانين
والاحتجاجات تحولت الى احداث شغب وقتل
ونحن وسقط من القاتله على الخلفيه دي
ظهرت بعض الشخوص المهمه اللي اثرت وقتها
في تاريخ فنزويلا اهم الشخصيه الشهيره جدا
اه هوجو شافيز
اذا كان ضابط في القوات المسلحه او كان
عند ميول يساريه ناس كثيره من ضباط اللي
موجوده في الجيوش امريكا الجنوبيه
او امريكا اللاتينيه بقه كمان يعني اكثر
شويه من امريكا الجنوبيه
والراجل ده شايف الاحداث اللي ب تجري يقرر
انه هو يعمل عمليه التعبير كان او لتغيير
فكر فيه محاوله انقلاب سنه اثنين وتسعين
لكنها كانت انقلابات انقلاب فاشل وتم
القبض عليه والقى في السجن وفضل مسؤول
لمده عامين لكنه خلال العامين يتواصل
برسائل مع الجمهور ابتدا يستقبل هذا الشاب
الثوري المفوض اللي عنده كاريزما وعنده
جاذبيه وقبول لدى الجماهير لما خرج اسس
حزب سياسي اشتراك يساري بيتكلم عن حقوق
الفاره و بيتكلم عن ظلم الاغنياء و بيتكلم
على في شركه للاعمال اللي كان بيقول عليهم
انهما بيقوم حافلات دعاره بيشربوا الويسكي
والناس تغلبه في الشوارع
في النهايه الشعبيه الجارفه لشافيز القميص
الاحمر الشهير
قبضوا الى السلطه وتولي السلطه في فبراير
سنه تسعه وتسعين
الراجل دا ب الخلفيه دي ابتدا يتبنى
سياسيه كلها باختصار عشان تقاتل دستوري
نختصر عليكم كلها سياسات مستفزه للولايات
المتحده
تتكلم سنه تسعه وتسعين يعني بعد انتهاء
الاتحاد السوفياتي وسقوط بعد انتهاء الحرب
البارده ما قالت الولايات المتحده انه في
ال الحديقه او في الفناء الخلفي للولايات
المتحده نظام مش بس بدي اتكلم على اه مثلا
كوبا في منطقه الكاريبي احنا بنتكلم على
دوله ودوله من صغيره بالمناسبه عدد سكانها
ثلاثين مليون نسمه و دوله غنيه بالنفط
فيها زعيم عنده قبول واسع جدا وفي نفس
الوقت ان يتبنى اجنده معاديه للسوق
المفتوح والسياسات الامريكيه والهيمنه
الامريكيه وبيحاولوا ماده ايده لخصوم
الولايات المتحده الكبار زي الصين وروسيا
بس وقتها كانت في البدايه روسيا وبعد كده
بيت روسيا والصين التي استعادت لاحقا
عافيتها ابتدا كمان يحاول يكون تحالف من
دول ويدعم حكومات مناوئه للولايات المتحده
في ال اه امريكا اللاتينيه وفي منطقه
الكاريبي المسائل التي كلها لا تستطيع
الولايات المتحده زي ما قلت ال حضراتكم
انهى تغفره او تتساهل
قصه طويله هي اقتصاد امريكا امريكا
الشركات بتكون فكرت ها كله على مصالح
شركتها ومصالح البزنس متاحه اذا كان نظام
من الانظمه ورفع شعار الاشتراكيه واغلق
اسواق وابتدا يرفع شعارات مماثله عبد
الناصر مثلا في الستينات او اكثر من كده
مماثله لفلسفه وشعارات محمد علي باشا في
مصر سنه 1805
محمد علي تتحملها ولذلك لو نرجع للتاريخ
على ان محمد علي الضرب لانه رفض فتح اسواق
مصر للبضائع الغربيه في مساله لا يمكن ان
تتقبلها بدات العلاقه تلتهب ما بين
البلدين وبدا من فتره مبكره جدا يعني بعدم
دخول والسلطه باقل من اربع سنوات اتهم
الولايات المتحده لانها اعتبرت محاوله
انقلاب دكتو في الفين واثنين وتصاعد
الخلاف وصل الخلاف المتصاعد ما بين رئيس
دوله صغيره في امريكا اللاتينيه يقلد كل
عواد من البترول والشعبيه ضد الولايات
المتحده والولايات المتحده بتحصل من كل
مكان لكن كانت عاملين العامل الاول ان
اسعار البطوله في الفتره كانت مرتفعه
والولايات المتحده نفسها رقم احد اهليه
كان تستورد اربعين في المائه من انتاج ومن
البترول وبالتالي كان عنده تدفق كان عنده
رغبه وحرص على ان يوزع عوائد البترول عائد
البترول ذهب اكبر قدر ممكن من العداله
والكفاءه الممكنه وبالتالي ادري ينجح في
فتره هو حكم حوالي 13 سنه يعني من سنه
تسعه وتسعين ل 2013 14 سنه قدر انه يعمل
الانجاز ضخم جدا
الانجازات ضخمه جدا انه ادري خفض الفار
بارقام الصندوق وارقام اخرى النقدي يعني
انه قد انخفضت الفارق تقريبا النص يعني
كان عدد الفقراء لم نستلم السلطه خمسين في
المائه حبهم ل حوالي تسعه وعشرين في
المائه انخفضت البطاله بشكل كبير انخفضت
معدلاته وفعلا الاطفال اه تحسنت انتعاش
الاقتصاد في فنزويلا والفقره احب هذا
الرجل كثيرا فهو كان عنده امور تدعم
وشخصيته الرجل زي ما قلت ال حضراتكم كان
يتكلم مع الشعب حوالي 40 ساعه اسبوعيا في
حوارات مفتوحه من الرجل التلفزيون وال
بيعمل اجتماعات وعلى الهواء كانت حاله
البترول زي ما قلت لحضرتك دعم ضد رغبه
الولايات المتحده في الاطار
لكن الرجل ده يعني اه اه ت اه سنه 2013
بعد معركه مع السرطان
صغير السنه حوالي ثمانيه وخمسين قبل بيصعد
شخصيه اخ اخرى اللي هو الرئيس الحالي
نيكولاس مادورو
دور من نفس المدرسه لكن معندوش حاجتين ما
عندوش الحاجه الاولانيه انه ما عندوش نفسي
جاذبيه ولا كلمه شافيز والاهم انه ما
عندوش نفسه عوائد البترول العذر انه تولى
السلطه في ابريل 2013
وبعدها بعده شهور قليله كانت اسعار
البترول حصلت احد كبيره وحصلت انخفاض كبير
مقدرش يتعافى منه وحتى لما الاسعار تحسنت
بعد كده كانت العقوبات الامريكيه اللي
فرضت عليه بسبب استمرار وفي سياسات شافيز
تقريبا شلت الاقتصاد الفنزويلي تماما بحيث
انه حتى لما بقى فيه عوائد قليله بتيجي من
البترول هو مش قادر ي البترول لانه البنيه
اللي بينتج فيها البنيه التحتيه
المعامل المصانع المضخات بقيت يعني قديمه
ومتهالكه وما بين فقد عليها ما فيش
استثمار عليها وبالتالي انخفضت ان تابوا
من النفط بغض النظر عن البيئه وحوالي خمسه
وثلاثين في المائه انخفض الاحتياطات من
حوالي اه ثلاثه واربعين في 2009 ثلاثه
واربعين مليار دولار الفين وتسعه وقد رقم
هائل جدا الى اقل من تسعه مليار في يوليو
الحقيقه بشكل كبير جدا الى درجه انه ديك
برقم او اثنين ولكم الاوضاع في فنزويلا
اللي احنا بلد من حسن الاختيار مش من حيث
الانتاج الاحتياطي الموجود على الارض وصل
التدخل
بمعدل ثلاثه في المائه يومين يعني الاسعار
اليوم اليوم بزياره ثلاثه في المائه كل
يوم يعني بنتكلم كده على حوالي اربعين الف
في المائه في السنه وفيه واحد مسؤول في
صندوق النقد كان قال من حوالي سنه وشويه
انا استبعد ش ابدا في نهايه 2018 2019 ان
احنا نلاقي التضخم على اساس سنوي حوالي
مليون في المائه الاسعار بقيت شيء مش
مقبول
النتيجه ان احنا الان اقدام ازمه انسانيه
هذا البلد الغني ما فيش في الحكومه عجزه
عن توفير الدواء عاجزه عن توفير الامن
عجزه عن توفير الغذاء عاجزه عن اداره كثير
من المؤسسات اللي ممكن يحصل في فنزويلا في
الفتره المقبله الله اعلم فنزويلا مفتوحه
على المنكوب لانه الرئيس اللي موجود مدور
يقدر يعارض الى الابد لكنه ما يقدرش يعيد
الاستقرار الى بلد معندوش مقومه الاستقرار
والاخوان جريده يقدر يكون عندهم محدده
كلها ودعم الولايات المتحده ودعمها غيرها
من الدول لكن كون الولايات المتحده نفسها
ب تدعمه ده معناه انه محكوم عليه بعدم
الشعبيه في بلد يشق في الولايات المتحده
ولايات فيه وما زال بيحل بافكار
شافيز والولايات المتحده كالعاده دائما
عندها قدره البلد سواءا عسكريا او
بالعقوبات لكنها دائما عن البلاد اشكركم
والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله